buenas tardes creo que todos tenemos un
anecdotario un anecdotario personal
cuando entré a la policía hace 14 hace
16 años
quería cumplir muchas expectativas pero
no me imaginé que llegase a cumplir
tantas y en tan poco tiempo y les voy a
hablar de un periodo de mi vida de
cuatro años cuatro años donde conocí la
profundidad y la diversidad
de la colombia profunda y también de un
escenario internacional que ya les
comentaré
el primero de ellos trabajar en el
departamento de bolívar y
específicamente en el sur en la
inmensidad aya de la mojana bolívar
encia de la depresión momposina sin duda
alguna la confluencia de estos elementos
naturales hacía que la expectativa fuera
todos los días mayor y que los sueños
se tratarán de materializar con más
ahínco y porque porque lo estaba viendo
desde la óptica del policía que era
necesario para mejorar las condiciones
de esas comunidades seguidamente tuve la
gratísima oportunidad de representar a
mi país ya mi institución en una misión
de paz en haití ese maravilloso país
con grandes dificultades que comparte la
isla la española allí al lado de la
república dominicana en la américa
insular
y tuve la gran pero la gran satisfacción
de empezar a juntar muchísimos episodios
que marcaron mi vida y signan desde ese
momento es el sendero vital de mi
existencia el norte vital empezó a
cambiarse porque
porque me di cuenta de que había que
valorar las pequeñas cosas que tenía en
abundancia en mi país que tenía en
abundancia en mi casa en mi ciudad
en mi entorno familiar y en mí y en mi
entorno de amigos
les comento que una vez
me invitó una señora oficial del
batallón de bangladesh
a una cena y como llegue yo allá porque
resulta que habían unas monjitas
colombianas la madre gloria a la madre
pilar que la hermanita pilar es una
señora de 85 años pero le daba a uno la
mano con una fuerza y una vitalidad
envidiable y ellas tenían una obra muy
bonita en el sector de cría de buque un
sector bastante difícil y que fue entre
otras cosas el sector más golpeado
durante el terremoto de 2010 y que dejó
más de 300.000 muertos en la capital
haitiana
y porque busque a través incluso de
facebook y de whatsapp y de la web haya
interna de naciones unidas- búsqueda a
ese batallón porque era el único
batallón que tenía una ginecóloga una
ginecóloga que era absolutamente
necesaria para darle un poquito de
vitalidad a la salud de muchas niñas que
estaban pasando por penurias de salud en
el sector oeste de la ciudad capital de
haití
llevamos a la ginecóloga acompañado de
otros profesionales de la salud pero de
otros componentes policiales y militares
que hacían parte de la misión de paz y
sin duda alguna empezamos a configurar
una mancomunada insuperable que la dis
lideraba a la policía de colombia pero
que era acompañada de manera súbita
espontánea con mucha alegría por parte
de otros componentes y odontólogos iban
recreacionistas iván médicos iban otros
profesionales porque les interesaba
mucho ayudar porque ese concepto de
solidaridad verdaderamente se establece
cuando se observan necesidades mucho
pero muy mayores a las que tenemos en
nuestros países
y saben que era lo más
lo más significativo de todo observar
como esas poblaciones y esos niños
disfrutaban y se les veía la alegría
cuando veían observar a la distancia la
llegada o el acercamiento mejor de un
carro tanque con agua con agua agua que
nos sobre a nosotros
le recuerdo que el páramo de sumapaz que
lo tenemos aquí cerca es el páramo más
importante y más grande del mundo pero
allá en esas en esos sectores tan
distantes de las realidades de las
realidades prósperas un simple
carrotanque para sembrar unos arbolitos
que nos regaló recuerdo un vivero de la
del centro de puerto príncipe que se
llama pétion ville para que germinara
creciera para que fuera testigo de ese
poquito de desarrollo y de prosperidad
que le estábamos entregando un grupo de
sudamericanos y de asiáticos que
estábamos llegando constantemente de
manera desinteresada hoy en día se
mantiene el contacto con esa comunidad
hoy en día esas personas todavía siguen
añorando que volvamos porque se sembró
huella porque se sembró una inmensa
semilla hoy en día han pasado cuatro
años desde nuestro regreso y sin duda
alguna es una enorme satisfacción
cuando se mire en retrospectiva y se
dice misión cumplida misión cumplida
al poco tiempo regresamos y a mí me
asignan una responsabilidad bien
interesante en una zona de cierto modo
parecida a la ínsula haitiana y
dominicana pero esta vez en san andrés
islas y ese hermoso archipiélago rodeado
por ese mar azul turquesa y enriquecido
por esa reserva en la biosfera seaflower
pero entramos y empiezo a hacer una
serie de comparaciones y en pie empiezo
a aterrizar esas enseñanzas dejadas por
las poblaciones del sur de bolívar y
dejadas también por los pobladores de
haití y particularmente de su capital
puerto príncipe y establecemos unos
lazos de amistad bien fuertes con las
comunidades raizales y entender e
interpretar cuál es su sentir
entender que la comunidad raizal es una
comunidad centenaria una comunidad
respetable una cultura que es
transversal no solamente al archipiélago
colombiano sino que es transversal
también a otros lugares a otros lugares
del encantador mar caribe de esa zona de
nuestro continente es por ello que lo
más importante lo más importante es
observar esas pequeñas cosas esos
pequeños detalles esas vivencias para
transportarlas aterrizarlas en unas
nuevas para hacernos todos los días unos
mejores policías unos honestos
ciudadanos y ante todo unos buenos seres
humanos muchas gracias